the UN's refugee agency is calling for a
more comprehensive european-wide
search-and-rescue operation for migrants
at the moment the vast majority of the
work is borne by Italy's Coast Guard
ladder bring in the more than at five
thousand migrants you were hearing about
their that arrived between last Saturday
Monday required 18 landing operations to
these Italian ports as you can see Beck
and those other people of course who
survived the journey the UNHCR says that
900 migrants have died or gone missing
at sea so far the ship now last year as
a whole 3500 migrants died that up from
600 in 2013 now many of those attempting
the journey are escaping the conflict in
Syria and oppression in Eritrea now of
the thousand or so unaccompanied
children who arrived in Italy since the
start of this year sixty-two percent
almost two out of three of those are
from Somalia gambier and Eritrea and
fifty-nine percent of the almost 500
accompany children were from Syria let's
get more on this now joining me now from
at Geneva is William Spindler he's from
the UN's refugee agency unhcr good
evening a factor joining us on Sky News
Tonight now of course this follows the
end of a more comprehensive search and
rescue operation in 2014 what was known
as marring nostrum how much of a
difference with an operation like that
make it terms of a disaster like this
well Mary nostrums save over a hundred
thousand lives last year and what we see
now is that a combination of a
diminished capacity to save people in
the Mediterranean and in an increase in
the number of people trying to come to
Europe is having the effect that more
people are trying to come and losing
their lives in the in the process and
that's why we think it's urgent to do
something to stop this humanitarian
crisis in the in the Mediterranean and
you've got a very specific set of
proposals haven't you that you're put
into European countries just run us
through those well obviously these are
very complex issues and they cannot be
addressed by a single country I mean we
we have heard the impact of this in a
small community in Italy and this is
obviously a problem that it's beyond the
capacity of a single country but it's
not beyond the capacity of the EU as a
whole we are talking about a combined
population of 500 million people in the
European Union so surely we can find a
ways to address these issues one of the
ways is to increase the capacity to save
people in the range Mediterranean at the
same time we think that people should be
helped where they are at the moment most
refugees are not coming to Europe but
they are staying closer to the countries
they come from in the case of Syrian
Prince's most of them are staying in the
neighboring countries Lebanon Jordan
Turkey and Iraq alone are hosting nearly
four million Syrian refugees and we
think that this country's need help in
order to continue to host this this
large number of refugees so that these
refugees don't need to come in this long
dangerous journeys to Europe and that
also it links to the other proposal that
we are making we should look into the
possibility of legal safe ways for
refugees to come into Europe through
resettlement programs through
humanitarian admission programs that
kind of initiative has been done in the
past during the Bosnian crisis for
instance when there were hundreds of
thousands of Bosnian asylum seekers and
refugees in Europe they were accepted
Inc in Europe and eventually they return
to their country once peace was restored
so we think that something similar can
be done now now for Syrian refugees of
course we can see they know the
desperate human cost of pageants is like
this in the fact that something must be
done but a lot of European countries say
you know we can't afford we have our own
problems in terms of our economies we
can't afford to spend the
from money we don't want to encourage
and we've heard this my own government
we don't want to encourage further
migrants to come across how do you
convince them otherwise we understand
that immigration is a hugely
controversial issue in Europe and of the
recent economic crisis and the people
are worried about this but at the same
time we should remember that these are
not economic migrants the map the dust
majority of them are refugees fleeing
conflict and persecution and human
rights violations they have no choice
and we need to make sure that that
without and they are fleeing for their
lives literally we think that it's not
beyond the capacity of Europe to offer
some places for for for for for some of
these refugees but of course the vast
majority of refugees need to be helped
where they are at the moment in
countries closer to two to those where
they come from of course you paid
commission actually does focus on some
of this it's thrown up its own policy
document the European agenda on
migration and you must be familiar with
the contents of this I mean it's got
things for example a plan to fight
smuggling offshore processing centers
what do you make of those kind of
proposals at you n hcl well the
situation is so critical in the middle
arena that we need to explore all the
possible solutions and probably what we
need to do is a combination of several
things we need to address the root cause
of the other problem which is war and
human rights violations and we need to
activate the capacity of the
international community to solve
conflicts such as that in Syria and now
in India and elsewhere but that's one
thing that we need to do in the
countries that are actually producing
the refugees then as I said we need to
help the refugees where they are mostly
which is the country's neighboring those
that are at war but also Europe needs to
play a role in this and that's why we
are looking into the possibility of
ordered legal ways of refugees to come
to Europe and we can explore all these
different possibilities and it needs to
be done in a way that it's fair because
as we have seen some countries are
bearing the brunt of this and we would
like to your
you need to take a leading role in
finding solutions for what is a very
complex international problem and just
briefly if you will sir we've seen that
the fatality rate is going up but it
does look like this isn't putting people
off this issue is going to get bigger it
looks like that and unless we do
something we will see more tragedies
like the one we just seen in the last
few days more people are going to die
and I think that this is unacceptable
and most people in Europe are distressed
when they see these images of children
and women and men growling in the
Mediterranean simply because they want
to find safety and a better life indeed
Williams member thank you for joining us
thank you